mr bell looked like brooks and dumb yeah
you can be saved bro we've never seen
no i've never seen a picture of
chappelle in school dude he's always
dancing in the gym yeah it's always
recess where chabella
oh he's doing flips yeah a lot of the
kids in the background are in
wheelchairs i'm like
this seemed like a unique environment i
did take the short bus when i was
younger
yeah oh what happened nothing happened
to me you get roasted when you got off
because at my school the
short bus kids got lit the [ __ ] one kid
no i don't i don't condone that but
that's just the way the world oh one of
the sb kids came one time in our school
when dude he'd had enough right he had
enough of his
shoot that [ __ ] up uh he brought a
bunch of uh
blazing rockets hand rockets whatever
those things are called black cat
sparkles he's called out rockets
yeah and he just started unleashing on
people this backwards can still you know
you know attack people at school with
fire but not like guns you know and not
be sent home for the rest of the year
yeah
yeah and he got p you know they made him
stay outside and pick up garbage or
something for half the day but that's
how it should be dude that's what that's
what i had to do in junior high
they gave me community service every
[ __ ] dude that wasn't junior high if
you got community service that was
important
also also you're probably a grown man in
junior high school
kids don't get committee service dogs
that's what they did to me
yeah i promise you yes this is arizona
somebody lied
a lot about where you were when you were
a kid man did they yeah yeah
somebody's like oh you just have to take
this short bus just because that's
insane
even though you're a real thing even
though you're 18 you're in junior high
i don't know how they're doing arizona
bro yeah
you gotta i think we got to delve into
your history a little bit
tighten up yeah yeah we wanted to get
you into one of those on
like uh you might have to do ghb or
something what is it called what's gh
oh yeah where you get your degrees
that's a drug that's a good thing oh
i'm down to watch him do ghb but i'm
also down for him to get his ged
yes i graduated high school
a lot of the references i'm just saying
maybe go back over when i kill you yeah
yeah i want to be in a cap and gown i
promise that doesn't prove anything
i could buy one right now hold on man no
y'all dude i think you were in the
church
choir i don't know what that was yeah
oh no yeah i've been to a lot of affam
churches and it is
everybody's in it everybody's in a cap
and gown in that thing where
i graduate even at the funerals every
now and then you'll see just like some
the black coffin will be like uh he'll
just pop up
i mean everybody that's one picture i
got some school pictures y'all hating
i think you're confusing community
service with graduation
i know i did it didn't i do it dog nick
nicki minaj was like yeah we had the
license plate making class
i'm like no i'm telling you
look at that bad boy oh he's
bullshitting around chappelle
bad boy is correct dude that's obviously
a kid
who would have been uh taken out of
class for some reason no that was
that was a legend okay you went double
button yeah come on man look at my full
latina i got my teammates
right here look go ahead nick show that
one that's in high school the latino top
button
let's see some of these other freaking
alleged we're all
we're all your friends uh latino in uh
oh
this ain't school chapelle yeah that's
what that's my cheer photo
again not school that's an outside
activity
oh you and a bunch of marilyn manson
looking to win
bro look at me look at that dude roll on
the top left
this guy ain't in school yeah he was i
thought they took this off netflix
there you go i was a g let's see one
more
one more
hey i'm right there you see me this
ain't college bro no
i see no degree that's miss classics
class bro come on now
you telling me dude little dude on the
bottom left if that dude's in college
bro
well that's not called a little illegal
alien you know that dude's over there
bro
damn who's that big button next to you
with a hat on
where big old mean gene with the hat on
in the blue
yeah who's that little skirt on your on
your right
who's lizzo on the far right doug top
[Laughter]
rope
well i'm just saying it's there's the
minority is the white
the white there yeah they had two white
oh is there any other black people in
there
no it's just you a lot of latino ones
scared white girl in the middle
you got that hawaiian girl on the bottom
right dude that white that white dude uh
on the far right no no no no go down the
gu
he's got like the no go up go up the
blonde white kid
that one yes that [ __ ] was a nut
oh yeah he looks like
crazy dude i could have guessed i could
he probably killed his parents one of
those kids that'll hide a grape in his
butt dude
for no reason
[Music]